a musical yes it is but it has
rock'n'roll Rock of Ages
alright so Rock of Ages as a musical it
follows this one girl she's from a small
town she goes to Hollywood she meets a
guy they had the little love interest
thing going on all the while there's
like musical numbers you know it's like
a musical you know like The Sound of
Music
except with rock'n roll I can't say no
to something like that so among this
girl and this guy having a little love
interest thing they both work at this
one place where Alec Baldwin and Russell
Brand they pretty much own it and by it
I mean the bar and the entire movie
because they do they don't own the
entire movie I'll get there in a second
but these two kicked ass they're funny
as hell the ridiculous the characters
are cartoons but in a movie like this
you're okay with it because you're like
it's a musical based around rock and
roll so you don't mind the fact that
these characters are just ridiculous
people however then we see him the man
himself Tom Cruise yeah I would say
Stacee Jaxx played by Tom Cruise but I'm
pretty sure Tom Cruise had no idea he
was being filmed in this movie however
IMDB informs us that it's not Tom Cruise
playing Tom Cruise is Tom Cruise playing
the rock god Stacee Jaxx you know what I
like about Tom Cruise at one point he's
like yeah I lost my mind I jumped on
Oprah's couch I'll do roles like Tropic
Thunder and Stacee Jaxx in Rock of Ages
I like the fact that the guy takes his
perception that people see him as which
is you know kind of a crazy guy right
now he just uses it as a strength he's a
man-child rock god going through a
meltdown yeah you know you want to watch
it now other than that the musical
numbers are complete kick-ass seriously
this is the reason to watch this movie
yeah you got your little love story and
some little musical numbers are kind of
cheesy but when you have musical numbers
based around rock and roll you know Def
Leppard Tom Cruise someone asked Tom
Cruise a question and upon him thinking
about his answer you hear Bon Jovi
queuing up yeah I'm not gonna lie I got
excited I got excited like a middle-aged
soccer mom I thought it was badass
the music's the reason to watch it I'll
say that this is like some of the
coolest covers I've heard does the movie
have its flaws yeah it does is everyone
gonna like the movie not at all there's
a certain point in the movie where the
story arcs start branching out you're
like well I hate that but this is
awesome I'll tell you this if you like
rock and roll if you like music if you
even like recognizing when the death of
rock and roll happened and how if you
like the wedding singer if you profess
that grand theft auto vice city is the
best
Grand Theft Auto games you're gonna
enjoy Rock of Ages dude I'm telling you
you'll laugh you'll cry some parts would
be like ah this is way too soft other
parts you're gonna be like this is all
sorts of rock and roll kick-ass that's
why rock and roll in the 80s is the best
for me I would say I would buy Rock of
Ages on blu-ray rock and roll and by
blu-ray I mean I would probably go on
Amazon and buy the soundtrack but I
heard some of the demos on Amazon it's
just not the same you know you need the
5.1 surround you need to hear the crowd
you need Tom Cruise to slam the guitar
and have explosions of letters in the
background that are now on fire
I'm telling you it's like the movie
hairspray for straight people right so
your favorite 80s rock and roll song
dude you gotta have one everyone has one
dude I was blasting Def Leppard arounds
coming home from the movie theater after
watching this movie you can't help it
you just live the experience whatever
your favorite is comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more and
rock on
[Music]
you